هجوم واسع بصواريخ ومسيرات تتعرض له كييف
هجوم منسق يقول الجيش الاوكراني بصواريخ
بلديه وكروز تنطلق سفارات الانذار وتسقط
الدفاعات الجويه جميع الصواريخ بحسب الجيش
الاوكراني طال الهجوم معظم مقاطعات
اوكرانيا بما فيها الفيف في الغرب وفي
عداسا جنوبي البلاد 25 مسيره تستهدف
المدينه اسقطتها الدفاعات الجويه وكانت
تتجه لميناء تصدير الحبوب في منطقه
اسماعيل
بموازاه التطورات الميدانيه وصل وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انتن بلينكن الى كييف
زياره بلينكن تهدف للاستماع لتقييم حقيقي
حول تطورات الحرب من الاوكرانيين انفسهم
بحسب ما نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن
مسؤولين امريكيين وتقول المعلومات
المتوفره ان واشنطن ستقر مساعدات اضافيه
تزيد على مليار دولار لاوكرانيا بعدما
اكدت كييف لوشنطن انها تحتاج ذخيره وليس
مشوره بحسب الصحيفه ومن بين ما تطلبه نسخه
محدثه من صاروخ امرام ليغطي مسافه تتراوح
بين 160
و180 كيلومترا وهو صاروخ جو جو متوسط
المدى يبلغ وزنه
52 كيلوغراما وطوله قرابه اربعه امتار
المتحدث باسم القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه
اكد ان وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه طلب
التعديلات على الصاروخ واضاف بحسب وكاله
للاخبار ان الصاروخ سيمكن بلاده من ضرب
الطائرات الروسيه دون دخول منطقه الدفاع
الجوي في المقابل نقلت وكاله تاس ان
طائرات سوخوي 57
ستتزوج قريبا بصواريخ من الجيل الخامس من
طراز ار 37
يتراوح مداها بين 150 و300 كم وهو صاروخ
فرط صوتي تفوق سرعته سرعه الصوت بخمسه
اضعاف يستطيع الاشتباك مع اهداف طائره على
ارتفاع يتراوح بين 15 مترا الى 25 كلم
كل هذه الخطوات تصب في استراتيجيه عسكريه
مفادها ان من يتفوق في القدرات الجويه
يتفوق حتما في الحرب